mes chers collègues
bonjour à tous
nous allons pouvoir commencer nos
travaux nous sommes très heureuses avec
ma collègue berbel base de pouvoir nous
réunir aujourd'hui
ici madame
la présidente du bundeslag chez Herber
belle mesdames et messieurs les députés
chers collègues je suis l'ambassadeur
madame la préfète
c'est pour moi un honneur de présider
aujourd'hui au côté de madame la
Présidente du Bundes tag l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande
après la séance plénière si réussi qui
s'est tenue à Berlin le 7 novembre
dernier avec berbel et l'ensemble de nos
collègues parlementaires
nous avons la volonté commune de donner
toute la force toute la légitimité
qu'elle mérite à notre jeune assemblée
qui doit devenir le cœur battant de
notre coopération parlementaire
en ce jour anniversaire de la mort de
Victor Hugo
je veux d'abord saluer la mémoire de ce
grand Européen et de ce député
visionnaire qui dès le 21 août 1849
devant le Congrès de la paix réunis à
Paris déclarait ceci
un jour viendra
où les boulettes et les bombes seront
remplacés par les votes
par le suffrage universel des peuples
par le vénérable arbitrage d'un grand
Sénat souverain qui sera à l'Europe ce
que le Parlement est à l'Angleterre ce
que la diète est à l'Allemagne ce que
l'Assemblée législative est à la France
ce grand Sénat souverain de l'Europe que
Victor Hugo appelait de ce vœu est
devenu réalité c'est notre Parlement
européen
pilier central de notre vie démocratique
européenne
aujourd'hui nous avons l'honneur de
siéger dans l'hémicycle de cette
assemblée
transnationale unique au monde ici à
Strasbourg
cette cité de l'humanisme au Gutenberg
met au point l'imprimerie et qui
émerveilla Victor Hugo quand du rein
monté sur l'unique tour de la cathédrale
il nota
moi j'allais d'une tourelle à l'autre
regardant ainsi tour à tour la France la
Suisse et l'Allemagne un seul rayon de
soleil
chaque tourelle fait face à une nation
différente
en cette ville carrefour en jeu de tant
de guerre et de siège dans le passé il
nous appartient maintenant de bâtir un
avenir de Concorde et de paix
bien sûr le choix de nous réunir à
Strasbourg revêt une haute valeur
symbolique Strasbourg fruit d'une
histoire deux fois millénaire sur les
rives du Rhin au confins de nos deux
pays et le point nodal de la
réconciliation franco-allemande et de
notre partenariat commun au service
d'une Europe forte résiliente et
solidaire
c'est aussi le choix d'un ancrage afin
de mieux faire connaître notre assemblée
et ses réalisations concrètes en dehors
de nos capitales
et je saisis donc l'occasion de notre
présence ici pour exprimer notre profond
attachement au siège strasbourgeois du
Parlement européen
c'est d'ailleurs la deuxième fois que
notre assemblée se réunit ici après une
première session les 5 et 6 à 20 et je
tiens à remercier un nouveau
chaleureusement madame Roberta médecin
présidente du Parlement européen d'avoir
bien voulu mettre à notre disposition ce
superbe hémicycle
je remercie également brigitte Klinkert
qu'aux présidente française du bureau de
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande à qui nous devons cette
initiative de réunion décentralisée je
rends hommage à son investissement dans
le développement de cette assemblée
comme en matière de coopération
transfrontalière
je veux saluer également monsieur Niels
Schmitt qu'aux président allemand du
bureau de lapfa pour son engagement
constant ainsi que l'ensemble des
membres du bureau pour leur action et la
préparation de la séance qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui
les relations franco-allemandes
connaissent un nouveau dynamisme comme
en témoignent entre nos deux
gouvernements les nombreuses rencontres
bilatérales de ces derniers mois la
visite d'État du président de la
République française en Allemagne le 4
du 2 au 4 juillet prochain à
l'invitation de son homologue monsieur
Stan Mayer sera la première depuis
l'année 2000 ce qui confirme la ferme
volonté de donner un nouvel élan au
partenariat franco-allemand en cette
année anniversaire du traité de l'Élysée
pour cette commémoration du 60e
anniversaire du Traité de l'Elysée
l'Assemblée nationale et le Bundestag se
sont réunis à l'ASSE en assemblée
commune le 22 janvier dernier à la
Sorbonne à Paris cette magnifique
journée c'était conclue par la signature
d'une déclaration commune
abordons l'ensemble des sujets partagés
par nos deux assemblées parmi lesquels
l'énergie le climat les questions de
politique étrangères et de défense
l'apprentissage de la langue du
partenaire l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes ou encore la coopération
transfrontalière
autant de thématiques qui font
directement écho à vos travaux
au niveau parlementaire en effet je
mesure le chemin parcouru depuis
quelques mois et tout particulièrement
depuis la dernière séance plénière de la
fin les groupes de travail que nous
avons lancé pour approcher nos points de
vue nos méthodes et aboutir ainsi à des
positions communes ont procédé à une
série de d'auditions et d'échanges les
plus enrichissants
ainsi le groupe de travail sur l'avenir
de l'Europe a débuté ses travaux sous la
coordination de Madame constance le grip
et de Madame Chantal Coppe mercredi
dernier il a auditionné madame dubravca
swika vice-président de la Commission
européenne en charge de la démocratie et
de la démographie
réfléchir à la phase et le processus
d'élargissement de l'Union européenne
revoir les critères notamment en matière
des grandes le processus de décision
plus transparent vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens comme pour les états
candidats telles sont quelques-unes des
questions abordées dans le cadre de la
feuille de route ambitieuse que ce
groupe de travail s'est donné
sur la souveraineté énergétique celui
que coordonne nos collègues Monsieur
Frédéric petit et Monsieur André assiong
a entamé une réflexion indispensable sur
notre coopération en matière d'énergie
renouvelable et sur la stratégie
européenne pour l'hydrogène
au moment où la guerre revient sur notre
continent nous devons nous efforcer
ensemble de consolider la souveraineté
énergétique de l'Europe
après une première audition de Monsieur
SFEN Rosner directeur de l'Office
Franco-Allemand pour la transition
énergétique une table ronde avec des
chercheurs et experts de nos deux pays
se tiendra mercredi
des membres de nos deux gouvernements
seront auditionnés également
prochainement sur ces questions
complexes et délicates le bon
fonctionnement de ce groupe de travail
illustre la capacité de la FA à
rapprocher les points de vue grâce à ce
travail commun des parlementaires
franco-allemands
enfin le troisième groupe de travail
intimement liévène sera mis en place
très prochainement quoi que de nature
plus technique il abordera le sujet
crucial de la transposition convergente
des directives européennes en droit
national français et allemand
la coopération franco-allemande a
également trouvé sa place dans les
travaux des organes de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Bundestag de ce point de
vue je tiens à saluer ici l'engagement
exemplaire des commissions de la défense
de nos deux assemblées et à l'initiative
de leur président Monsieur Thomas
gacillou et Madame Marie-Agnès strike
Zimmerman qui sont devenus qui sont
convenus d'un programme de travail
commun et de rencontres entre les
membres des commissions dont la
prochaine se tiendra le 1er juin sur la
base aérienne d'Évreux celle de
l'escadron franco-allemand
déjà le 5 avril dernier l'audition par
la Commission de la Défense nationale et
des forces armées du général carst and
broyeur chef d'état-marin majeur de la
Bundes verts moins de 3 semaines après
sa nomination illustre la force des
liens qui unissent nos deux pays dans le
domaine militaire de même dans le
prolongement des célébrations du 22
janvier les commissions des affaires
étrangères et les commissions des
affaires européennes de nos deux
assemblées ont elles aussi organiser des
réunions communes
aujourd'hui l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée plénière et dense il s'inscrit
dans la dynamique créée par notre
déclaration commune du 22 janvier avec
plusieurs projets de délibération et de
résolution sur les questions
audiovisuelles et d'enseignement de
domaine clairement identifié dans le
traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle LAFA pourra se
montrer force de proposition pour mettre
en oeuvre les engagements pris et
confirmés par les toutes récentes
stratégies pour le développement de
l'apprentissage et de la langue
partenaire présenter le 24 novembre
dernier par nos ministres de l'éducation
et de la culture sur ces aspects nous
allons d'ailleurs profiter de cette
session strasbourgeoise pour rencontrer
les élèves du collège franco-allemand et
visiter le siège d'Arte deux
réalisations très concrètes en matière
de culture et d'éducation deux écoles de
la tolérance et de l'ouverture d'esprit
pour continuer de converger vers une
meilleure compréhension mutuelle
une résolution prévoit également la
constitution d'un groupe de travail sur
la politique étrangère et la sécurité
pour que l'APFA puisse contribuer à
l'analyse des menaces aux questions de
dissuasion nucléaire au programme visant
à renforcer nos bases industrielles et
technologiques de défunts sans présager
de votre vote je me réjouis que ces
débats s'ouvrent sur ces sujets
essentiels de même les travaux de
l'après-midi permettront d'aborder
d'autres sujets
d'intérêt commun avec l'audition du
ministre français de l'économie Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire et du ministre fédéral
allemand Monsieur Robert rabek puis un
débat qui s'annonce passionnant sur la
situation des Balkans occidentaux et
leur perspectives européennes il en
sortira une meilleure compréhension
commune et pourquoi pas des convergences
supplémentaires
chers collègues cherberbel vous le voyez
nous pouvons nous montrer
particulièrement fier de notre assemblée
commune de ces travaux de son dynamisme
ainsi que de son apport incomparable à
la relation entre nos deux chambres
ce résultat n'est pas venu tout seul il
traduit l'investissement de chacun
d'entre vous je ne puis que vous en
remercier vous souhaite une journée de
travail des plus fructueuse
[Applaudissements]
le 28
avions célébré l'amitié franco-allemande
à Paris
et nous avions rappelé l'importance
historique du traité de l'Élysée pour
nos pays mais aussi pour l'Union et
l'unité européenne
nous avons réfléchi aux grandes tâches
qui sont devant nous à notre
responsabilité commune pour l'Europe et
pour le monde
il me plaît de repenser à cette journée
et j'aimerais réitérer mes remerciements
à nos amis français en particulier à toi
chérie à elle merci beaucoup d'avoir
ainsi su organisé cette digne
célébration
l'ambiance qui règne à la Sorbonne comme
aussi à l'Assemblée nationale les
conversations les rencontres tout cela
je pense
nous a donné de nouvelles impulsions et
surtout un nouvel élan car nous en avons
besoin en ces temps-ci aujourd'hui nous
nous réunissons
pour travailler ensemble et ce n'est pas
un hasard si c'est au Parlement européen
que nous discutons ensemble merci à tous
ceux qui ont veillé à ce que nous
puissions être ici les autres de la
grande salle plénière du Parlement
européen cher collègues la guerre
d'agression russe contre l'Ukraine est
également
une attaque sur l'ordre sécuritaire
européen cela représente une césure pour
notre continent il nous faut donc
développer de nouvelles réponses et
c'est pourquoi nous mettons en place ce
nouveau groupe de travail politique
étrangère et de sécurité
pour moi cela signifie ceci en tant que
parlementaire nous faisons usageabilité
pour renforcer la paix la sécurité en
Europe les trois pattes collaboration
franco-allemande et là d'une importance
centrale et justement parce que nous
avons des traditions différentes en
matière de politique de sécurité
nous avons d'autres liens géographiques
et aussi d'autres empreintes historiques
il est important pour moi de souligner
ceci l'Allemagne assume de la
responsabilité pour la sécurité en
Europe nous faisons partie des plus
grands soutiens de l'Ukraine notre armée
la Bundes au cours des 30 années passées
une troupe utilisée pour des
interventions internationales maintenant
nous exécutons un changement fondamental
dans notre politique de sécurité et de
défense
l'Allemagne assume ses obligations dans
l'alliance ainsi nous avons encore une
fois renforcer notre engagement sur le
flanc Est de l'OTAN et nous faisons
notre contribution pour participer à la
dissuasion et la défense collective et
la dissuasion par l'OTAN est efficace en
mer j'étais enfin Landes avec l'adhésion
de la Finlande la frontière entre le
temps et la Russie a doublé là aussi
Poutine a fait une erreur de calcul en
effet la cohésion au sein de le temps à
devenir européenne n'a fait que sa
croître depuis l'agression russe sur
l'Ukraine l'Union européenne est un
projet de paix elle est la meilleure
réponse
au velléité violente
d'expansion de la Russie nous augmentons
également notre propre sécurité lorsque
nous donnons de Claire perspective
d'adhésion à des candidats des Balkans
occidentaux car nous ne savons bien les
attentes déçues rendent vulnérables
populisme elle déstabilise les sociétés
et les gens dans les pays des Balkans
sont de plus en plus déçus par l'Europe
je trouve qu'il est de notre intérêt
européen de donner aux états des Balkans
occidentaux une perspective claire
surtout aux jeunes gens c'est pas une
question de générosité non car en
essence il s'agit aussi de notre
sécurité et de la stabilité dans notre
Europe chers collègues nous vivons en un
temps où il y a des changements et c'est
pourquoi je suis heureuse de ce que nous
puissions poser des questions
aujourd'hui aussi au ministre d'économie
Bruno Lemaire et Robert avec et je me
réjouis de ce qui ne rejoindrons en
ligne
en effet ils sont tous les deux
compétents pour beaucoup de thèmes
centraux et décisés pour la
transformation de notre époque sécurité
énergétique protection du climat
préservation de la prospérité
compétitivité mondiale dans toutes ces
questions il faut que notre concertation
soit aussi étroite que possible et en
ces temps de transformation plus que
jamais dans toutes les questions qui ne
font pas l'unanimité nous le savons nos
notre force c'est justement de
transformer les différences en des
progrès pour l'Europe notre amitié et
notre coopération a déjà fait ses
preuves en de nombreuses crises parce
que nos entretiens sont ouverts et ne
négociations sont toujours équitables
chers collègues l'amitié
franco-allemande a été construite et
renforcée par beaucoup de gens au cours
de décennies voulons et nous devons
continuer de l'entretenir or la langue à
cet égard est un point important et il
me tient beaucoup à cœur car les
connaissances linguistiques sont la clé
à la compréhension mutuelle
malheureusement
il y a de moins en moins d'élèves
français qui apprennent l'allemand et de
l'élève allemand qui apprennent le
français
cette évolution est proprement
dramatique sans exagérer
dans l'une d'émotions d'aujourd'hui il
est question de faire revivre la langue
du partenaire dans l'école ce n'est pas
exagéré pour notre prochaine réunion en
décembre qui se tiendra à bonne il est
déjà prévu une audition du gouvernement
sur les questions linguistiques si nous
ne redressons pas le cas nous allons
perdre un élément essentiel une pierre
de construction de la compréhension
mutuelle et nous en tant que
parlementaire ne doit rester sur le coup
les échanges entre nos jeunesse ont joué
un rôle important au cours des décennies
passées
et ces échanges ont eu tellement de
succès parce que ces élèves
Habitat a pris la langue du partenaire à
l'école l'anglais ne peut remplacer cela
la présidente de Madame brande Pivet et
moi-même d'ailleurs elle a déjà évoqué
nous allons rencontrer cet après-midi
des élèves d'une classe bilingue je m'en
réjouis beaucoup de même que je me
réjouis de ce que nous allions visiter
ensemble
la chaîne de télévision culturelle car
la langue et la culture sont des piliers
de la compréhension mutuelle nous devons
aussi les renforcer chers collègues lors
de notre réunion d'ouverture à la
préfecture j'avais déjà cité Louise
Weiss qui disait l'Europe est une
question d'âme
elle en était Louise Weiss profondément
persuadé ou peut-on sentir cette âme
plus nettement qui s'est à Strasbourg et
en ce bâtiment qui porte le nom de
Louise Weiss je ne souhaite à tous une
réunion constructive et fructueuse merci
d'être tous venus à Strasbourg
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup cher berbère madame la
Présidente nous allons maintenant faire
notre traditionnel photo de groupe donc
pour ce faire nous allons vous rejoindre
dans les travers et puis après la photo
la séance sera présidée par les
présidents du bureau et Madame Basset
moi-même nous aurons le plaisir de vous
retrouver pour le déjeuner et nous nous
rendrons au siège d'Arte pour faire
cette visite et une interview nous
retrouverons au déjeuner et puis après
nous pourrons passer ensemble la séance
de l'après-midi avec l'audition des deux
notamment en début de l'après-midi je
vous remercie
c'est bon
et Messieurs les Députés
chers Nils c'est pour moi une immense
fierté et un grand bonheur de et en
honneur d'être là ce matin dans ce si
belle hémicycle du Parlement européen
pour ouvrir notre
session relative ce matin à l'examen des
propositions de textes et des
amendements de l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande permettez-moi à mon
tour et en tant que local de l'étape si
vous le permettez de le dire ainsi vous
souhaitez la bienvenue à Strasbourg
capitale européenne carrefour de
l'Europe qui est un véritable symbole de
notre unité et de notre engagement
envers la coopération entre nos deux
pays
c'est ici chers collègues que nos
destins se croisent que nos idées
s'entremêlent et que nos valeurs
communes trouvent écho je voudrais à mon
tour citer Victor Hugo qui déjà à
l'époque disait le Rhin réunis tout et
nous en sommes aujourd'hui ce matin le
meilleur exemple puisqu'en nous
réunissant aujourd'hui ici à Strasbourg
nous renouvelons notre engagement en
faveur de l'amitié franco-allemande qui
est la pierre angulaire de la
construction européenne je suis
convaincue cherniel chers collègues que
notre travail ici au sein de l'Assemblée
parlementaire va contribuer à encore
renforcer plus nos liens à aller plus
loin à favoriser la compréhension
mutuelle il y a oeuvrer en faveur d'une
Europe plus forte et plus unie nous
avons l'opportunité unique chers
collègues de façonner ensemble notre
destin commun en insufflant une nouvelle
dynamique à la coopération
franco-allemande je voudrais si vous le
permettez également au nom de vous tous
féliciter chaleureusement notre collègue
Armine l'achète qui a été nommée il y a
quelques semaines Commandeurs de la
Légion d'honneur en reconnaissance de
son engagement fort dans la coopération
franco-allemande toutes nos
félicitations chers amis
mes chers collègues nous souhaitent une
réunion riche riche en échanges sous le
signe du respect et de la collaboration
puis sur nous saisir cette occasion pour
avancer ensemble avec encore plus de
détermination et conviction vers un
avenir prometteur pour nos pays et pour
toute l'Europe
alors nous allons comme évoquer
maintenant
examiner l'ensemble des textes qui sont
soumis ce matin à
notre validation à nos votes ces
documents vous ont été envoyés par
courriel ils sont aussi mis à votre
disposition à l'entrée de la salle en
format papier
nous allons tout d'abord examiner les
deux propositions de délibération
intitulée
complément au délibération du 7 novembre
2022 et ensuite la proposition qui
institue un groupe de travail politique
étrangère et de sécurité nous passerons
ensuite à l'examen des deux propositions
de résolution commune relatives à
l'apprentissage et à l'enseignement de
la langue du partenaire et enfin nous
examinerons la proposition de résolution
commune intitulée promotion de l'amitié
franco-allemande par des mesures
d'accompagnement dans les domaines de
l'audiovisuel et de l'industrie
cinématographique commune
je vous rappelle les modalités de prise
de parole le bureau a convenu du
déroulement suivant chaque proposition
va être présentée par un ou deux de ces
auteurs pendant une durée
globale de deux minutes les autres
groupes s'il le souhaitent et bien s'il
le souhaite pourront ensuite donner un
avis aussi pour un temps maximal de 2
minutes
j'invite les membres qui souhaiteraient
s'exprimer au nom de leur groupe a
demandé la parole à l'issue de la
présentation de la proposition et puis
pour des raisons techniques les orateurs
sont pardon priez d'appuyer sur le
bouton de leur pupitre et de se lever au
moment où ils prennent la parole se
lever je pensais pour des questions de
caméra pour que vous puissiez bien
d'être pris en compte par elle lorsque
des amendements ont été déposés chacun
de ces amendements sera ensuite présenté
par un de ces signataires pendant une
durée d'une minute et les autres groupes
pourront s'ils le souhaitent s'exprimer
et donner leur opinion également pour
une durée d'une minute l'amendement sera
ensuite soumis aux voix et une fois que
tous les amendements auront été examinés
la proposition sera mise aux voix dans
son ensemble
je pense que c'est super pour tout le
monde alors je vous propose tout de
suite de démarrer l'examen des textes et
en l'occurrence de démarrer par la
proposition de délibération que Neil
Schmitt et moi-même vous proposons et
qui intitulé complément au délibération
portant institution des groupes de
travail du 7 novembre 2022 et je propose
de nous la présenter
de mon côté aussi je vous salue très
chaleureusement ici à nous sommes très
heureux de si j'ai une fois de plus au
Conseil de l'Europe puisque nous sommes
sans nous déjà tenu une réunion c'est
enceintes sacrées pour ainsi dire et
comme toujours de travail commence avec
un peu de quotidien donc
cette proposition
a pour but
les différents groupes de travail sur
des compléter pour l'énergie
et les autres questions d'actualité en
Europe donc chaque groupe politique aura
le droit d'envoyer un membre consultant
dans
les groupes déjà constitués la raison en
est que dans notre règlement intérieur
et dans
nos habitudes jusqu'à présent nous
avions une limite dans le temps par
rapport aux membres réguliers qui
peuvent à tout moment être renommés et
ce délai est très court donc cela
attirer notre attention car ce n'est pas
très judicieux dans la pratique parce
que il s'agit en général que de membres
et envoient consultatifs mais
l'expérience a montré que justement dans
ces groupes de travail comme
l'énergie ou l'avenir de l'Europe
il était judicieux
de désigner des députés donc nous
voulons ouvrir cette possibilité il nous
faut pour cela l'accord de cette
assemblée et c'est pourquoi nous avons
préparé cette proposition quelques peu
technique pour laquelle nous demandons
votre large assentiment je pense que
c'est dans l'intérêt de tous
de favoriser cette souplesse
également pour les groupes de travail
déjà
existent de l'Assemblée mais pour les
groupes de Truffaut également votre
assiettement que nous vous demandons
président cher Niels passé au vote je
vais donner la parole au membre de notre
assemblée qui souhaite intervenir sur
cette proposition pour une durée de 2
minutes est-ce qu'il y a des prises de
parole sur le sujet
ça n'est pas le cas et bien dans ce cas
je mets
cette proposition au vote
il n'y a pas de demande de parole non
qui est-ce qui est pour son adoption
je vous remercie est-ce qu'il y a des
votes contre
des abstentions à l'unanimité chez Nice
ce texte est donc adopté
nous allons passer à la proposition de
délibération suivante qui est dénommée
PV
2023,3 et qui concerne l'institution
d'un groupe de travail politique
étrangère et de sécurité au sein de
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemand c'est donc une
proposition que nous proposons Neil
schmitté et moi-même
nous allons vous présenter très
rapidement
donc dans le temps de deux minutes ce
texte et c'est moi qui vais démarrer
alors si nous vous présentons ce texte
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il pour
instituer un groupe de travail politique
étrangère et sécurité c'est que bien sûr
il nous semble important que dans le
cadre du développement de la coopération
franco-allemande en matière de politique
étrangère
nous puissions français et allemand dans
le cadre de ce groupe de travail
accompagné la mise en oeuvre de la
boussole stratégique de l'Union
européenne et aussi le renforcement du
pilier européen de l'OTAN
en particulier avec un certain nombre
d'aspects qui sont listés dans le
document qui vous a été distribué mais
il s'agit en particulier je voudrais
insister là-dessus de la contribution et
du point de vue franco-allemand pour
faire progresser la boussole stratégique
et il nous semblait important que dans
la situation que nous connaissions
géopolitique et bien nous puissions nous
accorder dans ce domaine ni de Schmidt
je te laisse compléter
merci beaucoup Brigitte
cette bonne tradition que nous avons des
changeurs fournis
en matière de politique étrangère de
sécurité nous pouvons la poursuivre avec
cela car nous savons que c'est une pièce
maîtresse de la coopération
franco-allemande et c'est justement
parce que nous avons cette guerre
d'agression de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine
qui a se braquer des regards sur la
sécurité européenne il est important de
rendre clair la dimension européenne
avec la mise en œuvre de cette boussole
stratégique de l'Union européenne
avec des cas différentes facettes
également une facette cyber sécurité
défense contre les drones mais au moins
de l'Union européenne et de l'OTAN
et aussi des questions technologiques
des questions de coopération
industrielle tout cela est cité dans
cette boussole et
c'est un vaste terrain donc nous serions
heureux d'avoir aussi un large soutien
d'examiner l'amendement qui a été déposé
je vais donner la parole aux membres de
notre assemblée qui le souhaitent pour
une intervention de deux minutes sur
cette proposition madame rabot
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le Président je pense que ce groupe de
travail est extrêmement important parce
que nos parlements ont des traditions
différentes en termes d'approche à la
fois sur la défense c'est sur les
affaires étrangères
typiquement nous ne votons pas les mêmes
choses quand on parle des budgets des
armées le Bundestag je crois au delà de
50 millions d'euros est appelé à voter
ce qui n'est pas le cas du Parlement
français donc c'est important d'avoir un
partage au sein de ce groupe de travail
des visions stratégiques ça c'est ce qui
concerne en fait le fonctionnement de
nos deux institutions
Assemblée nationale et puis quand on
sort de notre périmètre on se rend
compte aussi qu'il y a des groupes
privés
qui l'ont annoncé il y a deux semaines
et une dizaine de jours qui commencent à
se positionner sur ces sujets là
notamment sur les sujets d'espace de
stratégie sur l'espace et je pense qu'il
est par conséquent extrêmement important
que le Bundestag et l'Assemblée
nationale au sein de l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande puisse
déterminer des positions communes qui
véritablement conditionne la sécurité à
la fois nos deux pays mais bien au-delà
du continent européen je vous remercie
donc je vais m'occuper des prises de
parole allemande madame c'est à vous
excusez-moi oui je dois me lever
cher collègue
j'ai grand plaisir à être parmi vous
aujourd'hui et je crois que plus que
jamais en Europe et dans le monde nous
dépendons d'une coopération efficace
c'est vraiment soudée surtout en des
questions de politique étrangère et de
sécurité
et
notre groupe de travail doit servir à
nous échanger car il y a encore beaucoup
besoin d'agir malgré ce qui a déjà été
fait et je pense que les stratégies de
nos deux pays ne devons les rapprocher
encore davantage dans les domaines
concernés dans les et dans les
structures de l'OTAN et de l'Union
européenne au sens de nos valeurs
communes et pour favoriser cela dans
notre groupe de travail nous voulons
jeter un coup d'oeil sur ce que nous
appelons là la boussole stratégique et
veiller à ce que ça soit couronné de
succès car cette boussole stratégique
joue un rôle tout à fait essentiel à cet
égard en particulier il s'agit de la
gestion de crise de l'Union européenne
qui doit être accélérée et rendu plus
efficace il s'agitation des capacités
militaires d'avoir de la résidence de
construire une résilience contre les
menaces et avant tout continuer de
renforcer ce que fait le temps
donc ici le travail conjoint de
l'Allemagne et de la France est
essentielle est indispensable nous
sommes dans le même bateau et nous avons
une direction commune pour tous les
États membres et les mécanismes
complexes des politiques de défense et
de sécurité
si nos stratégies propres sont s'avère
trop forte l'Union européenne pourra pas
être ce grand partenaire qu'elle doit
être et au plus tard depuis la guerre
d'agression contre dukraine cela ne
serait plus nous suffire la sécurité de
l'Union européenne et de ses valeurs
n'est plus garantie suffisamment c'est
pourquoi je peine en faveur de la mise
en place de ce groupe de travail en
particulier de la boussole stratégique
en faveur d'une compréhension mutuelle
pour cette approche sécuritaire
merci beaucoup de m'accorder la parole
voici ce que j'aimerais dire tout
d'abord
je pense que nous devons nous rappeler
ce que dit Henry Kissinger
car si je cite bien
quotidien d'aujourd'hui il dit nous nous
trouvons dans une situation classique
d'avant-guerre au vu de la confrontation
des grandes puissances des USA et de la
Chine ou aucune des parties n'a beaucoup
de marches de manœuvre pour des
concessions politiques et où tout
changement
ou tout déséquilibre pourrait avoir des
conséquences désastreuses
fin de citation alors nous n'avons pas
défini d'initiative
pour dire que peut-être ce groupe de
travail pourrait aussi se pencher sur
des initiatives de paix certes dans le
conflits dramatique ou nous nous
trouvons au niveau mondial et pas
seulement avec l'Ukraine mais
manifestement aussi avec la Chine comme
des cris qui singer comment
pourrions-nous contribuer à une détente
je pense que si nous
restons aveugle à ce point il nous
manquera quelque chose ce sera
unilatéral simplement nous focaliser sur
une politique d'armement ou de défense
nous ne pouvons pas donner notre
sentiment
merci chers collègues côté français j'ai
des demandes de parole de madame hamley
monsieur cloué et Monsieur Hetzel
et
je vous remercie donc Madame
monsieur le Président chers collègues
concernant la position du rassemblement
national il est évident que la
proposition de délibération d'un état
actuel de sa rédaction déborde trop
souvent sur le hors sujet lorsqu’elle
entendu renforcer le pilier européen de
l'OTAN la coopération franco-allemande
fondée sur l'alliance de deux peuples
frères et l'expérience de multiples
conflits doit se passer de tout
intermédiaire étranger si elle veut être
à la hauteur des liens qui les unissent
ainsi de la même manière que notre
assemblée franco-allemande oeuvre pour
étendre toujours plus l'apprentissage de
la langue allemande en France et de la
langue française en Allemagne nous
devons œuvrer en matière de politique
étrangère à renforcer notre relation
bilatérale c'est-à-dire soyons clairs à
nous passer d'un intermédiaire
anglo-saxon tel qu'il soit dans le cadre
des travaux de notre assemblée il est
très clair que l'Union européenne et
l'OTAN sont des outils de développement
et non une fin en soi nos deux pays sont
déjà les principaux contributeurs de ces
organisations multilatérales dans
lesquelles nous jouons chacun un rôle de
premier
en somme cette proposition délibération
est inquiétante car sa rédaction
actuelle
entretient le flou sur les objectifs que
devra précisément poursuivre ce groupe
de travail notre assemblée ne peut se
permettre de semer les graines de
l'incompréhension entre nos deux peuples
mes chers collègues travaillant ensemble
pour créer une synergie profitable
anneau de peuple je vous remercie
merci monsieur Adrien Clouet
merci madame la Présidente alors cette
résolution à un aspect assez
contradictoire d'un côté bien évidemment
dès lors que des parlementaires sont
habilités en capacité d'exercer leur
prérogatifs sur la politique étrangère
c'est un point d'appui mais en même
temps ce texte ne se contente pas
d'organiser un lieu de réflexion il
enjoint une série de conclusions et pose
le débat d'une manière qui nous paraît
peu adaptée pour ne pas dire largement
biaisé et ce sur deux points d'abord le
fait de réaffirmer l'attachement à
l'OTAN et simultanément à une politique
de défense européenne nous paraît
éminemment contradictoire puisque cela
signifierait que soit cette défense
européenne s'inscrit dans un cadre qui
n'est pas décidé en Europe soit que les
quatre décidaient en Europe seraient
contradictoire avec des cadres décidés
par ailleurs deuxièmement il y a
également une seconde de contradiction
de le d'ordre économique entre le vœu
Pieux de développer une base
industrielle autonome de défense et à
nouveau cette inscription maintenue dans
l'OTAN en termes notamment d'acquisition
du matériel et donc pour ces deux
raisons nous ne voterons pas cette
proposition telle qu'elle est formulée
merci à vous monsieur Zidane Stuhl
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues alors le hasard du calendrier
veut que nous débattions de ce sujet le
jour où l'Assemblée nationale française
commencera à examiner ce soir en
hémicycle la loi de programmation
militaire et nous serons bien entendu
tous les députés français présents ce
soir à Paris ou demain pour pour joindre
les travaux donc il y a une dimension
symbolique qui est qui nous échappe mais
en tout cas le calendrier a bien fait
les choses je pense que avec le groupe
ne Renaissance nous pensons que cette
délibération est extrêmement importante
puisque pendant des décennies et c'est
le fruit de notre histoire la différence
de puissance entre la France et
l'Allemagne sur le terrain militaire a
été clairement en faveur de la France et
l'Allemagne pour les raisons que nous
connaissons tous a eu pour la seconde
moitié du 20e siècle une armée
extrêmement réduite
tout cela a changé et le conflit entre
la Russie et l'Ukraine a peut-être été
le dernier élément qui a fait ouvrir les
yeux à
de nombreux responsables politiques des
deux côtés du rein et aussi en Europe
sur cette nécessité de renforcer une
politique de défense au niveau européen
et bien entendu
là-dedans la France et l'Allemagne comme
toujours sur les grands sujets
politiques en Europe tiennent une place
absolument éminente il faut donc que
nous réussissions à construire de part
et d'autre du rein une culture de
défense commune des convergences en
politique à la fois étrangère et de
défense et les parlementaires doivent
tenir une place éminente dans ce travail
là en tout cas le groupe Renaissance
soutient bien entendu cette délibération
merci
je prie Army de la chaîne de bien
vouloir prendre la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
notre groupe soutient également la mise
en place d'un tel groupe de travail et
ce que le collègue Ernst a présenté ici
même avec son introduction et si on
d'une citation de Kissinger en fait
devrait être pour et même participer à
ce groupe de travail et vouloir qu'on
trouve une position commune
franco-allemande donc moi je trouve ça
un peu contradictoire
cette seconde de travail ne devrait pas
faire des affaires quotidiennes me faire
ce qui est écrit dans le traité
d'Aix-la-Chapelle or il y est écrit
l'Allemagne et la France
s'accorde sur toutes les ce concertent
sur toutes les questions de politique
étrangère est-ce que cela se fait
actuellement pas particulièrement pas
pour tous les conflits du monde en effet
les prises de position sont divergentes
dans bien des cas que ce soit pour le
Moyen-Orient ou ailleurs dans le monde
et pour l'Union européenne donc il faut
regarder où il y a-t-il des points
communs où y a-t-il davantage point
commun les mécanismes entre les deux
ministères des Affaires étrangères
sont concordent-ils tout cela c'est la
tâche de ce groupe de travail dans la
formulation du projet de résolution
c'est un petit peu trop axé sur
l'ensemble de l'Union européenne car si
nous regardons là les évolutions
divergentes il est clair que ce n'est
pas notre groupe de travail qui va
pouvoir résoudre ça rien que des
différences entre la Pologne et la
Hongrie sur la guerre entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine il faudrait 20 groupes de
travail pour résonance alors nous avec
notre petit groupe de travail si nous
voulions encore donner 27 États membres
ce serait trop je trouve que nous
devrions nous concentrer sur l'Allemagne
et la France sur ce qui compte pour nous
poser des questions substantielles
également au gouvernement
invité aussi les ministres des Affaires
étrangères
en attendant deux qui deviennent pas
seulement sous forme numérique en ligne
et alors ce groupe de travail pourra
fournir une belle contribution
merci Monsieur Patrick Hetzel
beaucoup madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président mais mes chers collègues
effectivement ça ne vous étonnera pas je
vais aller dans le même sens que notre
collègue Army de la chaîne dans la
mesure où nous l'avons dit à de
nombreuses reprises notre groupe
parlementaire et favorable à ce que nous
puissions débattre dans la relation
franco-allemande et y compris aborder
les sujets qui sont parfois des sujets
de tension entre nous parce que
évidemment si les tabous qui peuvent
exister et bien nous ne les abordons pas
nous ne risquons pas d'avancer ensemble
or les questions à la fois de sécurité
et de politique étrangère sont des
sujets sur lesquels nous devons pouvoir
débattre raison pour laquelle nous
penchons que ce groupe de travail a tout
ça fait sa place et ce sera notre rôle
de faire en sorte que nous puissions
comme ça a été indiqué faire en sorte
que effectivement les ministres des
Affaires étrangères de nos deux pays
respectifs puissent aussi à un moment
donné venir devant notre assemblée que
nous puissions avoir cet échange avec le
effectivement de manière physique et non
pas de manière numérique comme cela sera
hélas le cas aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues comme vous n'avez
pas épuisé tout le temps de parole de
votre groupe je crois que monsieur a
aimé le souhaite de prendre la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente quelques
quelques mots pour se réjouir aussi de
notre côté sur la création de de ce
groupe mais effectivement les propos
assez large sur la boussole stratégique
sur l'OTAN mérite je pense le cadre de
cette enceinte qui nous est propre
l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande d'être sans doute
davantage ramasser sur les relations
franco-allemandes sur la stratégie
commune que nous devons avoir au-delà
des différents éléments militaires qui
sont les nôtres et qui seront débattus
ce soir à l'Assemblée nationale pour la
loi de programmation militaire et en ce
qui nous concerne on a un certain nombre
de sujets qui peuvent nous réunir
au-delà de la politique étrangère de
façon générale moi je pense qu'on a
vraiment intérêt à travailler sur la
cyber sécurité sur l'intelligence
artificielle ce sont vraiment des
éléments où nos deux pays peuvent mettre
en commun et avoir une stratégie qui
dépasse nos propres singularités ça
c'est l'INT érêt et peut-être aussi
accélérer un peu le calendrier il est
prévu un rendu des premiers travaux fin
2024 c'est vrai que si on pouvait le
faire d'ici à un an en juin 24 ça serait
peut-être préférable merci
merci beaucoup
madame monsieur le Président oui sur la
mise en place de ce groupe de travail je
pense qu'il est très important de le
mettre en place notre groupe
votre a pour en effet la mise en place
de ce groupe de travail souligne
l'entrée l'intérêt et le rôle des
parlements dans devant les grands défis
en matière de politique de sécurité que
nous avons devant nous en Europe et je
pense que c'est tout à fait juste
il n'y a pas seulement à en parler dans
nos parments nationaux pour savoir
quelle contribution la perspective
nationale pourra faire à la boussole
stratégique mais aussi en tant que
tandem moteur franco-allemand en tant
que les deux nations en Europe qui sont
toutes deux bien membres de l'OTAN et où
il y a de fortes grandes industries de
l'armement de grandes capacités
d'armement qui ont une forte diplomatie
et il faut que les parlements regardent
bien ce qui se passe au niveau exécutif
et comment ils peuvent accompagner cela
de manière constructive j'aimerais faire
encore une remarque sur ce crédit le
collègue du groupe de gauche je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait il n'y a pas ce
rétrécissement cette boussole
stratégique justement est large elle se
comprend comme à large base et
il faut se focaliser sur ce cette
boussole stratégique parce que tout y
est et que ce n'est qu'un si que nous
pourrons veiller à une cohérence de nos
politiques c'est pourquoi je plaide en
faveur de la mise en place des groupes
de travail
merci madame la Présidente au nom du
groupe démocrate moi je tenais à saluer
la pertinence de l'institution de ce
groupe de travail sur la politique
étrangère et la sécurité
d'une part en regard du contexte
international mais aujourd'hui mon
collègue
Charlie
a souligner que en France nous
commençons effectivement l'examen en
sciences publiques de la loi de
programmation militaire 2024-2030 comme
en Allemagne les budgets défense
augmentent dans chacun de nos deux pays
en France nous avons voté pour un budget
de inédit de 413 milliards d'euros pour
transformer nos armées et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le couple franco-allemand
doit être le moteur
doit être moteur pour renforcer notre
coopération alors évidemment on a encore
loin d'une Europe de la défense mais il
faut que le couple franco-allemand en
construisent les bases je reprendrai
quelques articles finalement de ce de la
proposition de constitution on a besoin
effectivement de l'établissement d'une
d'une boussole stratégique partagée
d'une analyse commune de nos menaces une
culture stratégique de la défense et je
voudrais rajouter quelque chose aussi
d'important qui a été souligné également
par mon collègue
Philippe Gosselin au-delà de l'analyse
du rôle d'analyse et de travail de
coordination de ce groupe de travail je
pense qu'il est important nous posions
les bases nouveau droit
franco-allemand qui n'existe pas encore
en matière d'intelligence artificielle
de robotique de cyberdéfense voilà tout
ce que je voulais dire et c'est pour
toutes ces raisons que le groupe
parlementaire donc démocrate votre a en
faveur de la création de ce groupe de
travail
merci chers collègues nous avons à
présent un amendement qui va être
présenté par Monsieur Charles zidstool
ah pardon monsieur Corbier je ne vous je
ne vous avais pas vu et surtout c'était
un par groupe il vous reste encore un
peu de temps
donc 30 secondes dans la continuité du
Adrien Clouet nous sommes évidemment
favorables à l'amitié franco-allemande
la discussion mais l'adoption de cette
résolution n'ouvre pas une discussion
elle la clôt elle l'a Claude il s'agit
d'un travail uniquement dans le
renforcement du pilier européen de
l'OTAN il s'agit de travailler nos temps
à l'interopérabilité du matériel de
défense qui signifie concrètement Matel
militaire compatible avec le matériel
américain cela se discute si cette
résolution est adoptée il n'y a plus de
discussion donc égal à une contradiction
cette résolution en l'état ferme la
discussion ne l'ouvre pas c'est
regrettable
merci alors j'ai 20 sentier beaux que je
n'avais pas vu non plus et ensuite il y
a plus tard avant la présentation de
l'amendement un sentiment
oui merci madame la Présidente au nom du
groupe horizon bien sûr nous allons
soutenir cette cette résolution qui nous
semble effectivement essentielle je me
permets juste d'assister juste sur deux
points effectivement on parle de de
stratégie en poésie étrangère en
sécurité je pense que là aussi il faut
qu'on puisse traiter aussi ça la notion
et ça a été dit sur le sujet de la cyber
qu'est-ce qu'on laisse souveraineté
européenne en termes de cybersécurité je
pense que là-dessus il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire c'est quelque chose c'est
pas encore tout à fait défini l'autre
sujet aussi si on parle de renforcement
du pilier européen je pense que nous
avons aujourd'hui encore des difficultés
des points de divergence qu'on peut
avoir entre la France et l'Allemagne sur
notamment des systèmes d'armement sur
des systèmes de de aussi de doctrine
militaire et je pense que c'est aussi
l'occasion dans le cas de ce groupe de
pouvoir les mettre en œuvre parce que
le si on le souligne le problématique
nous avons actuellement c'est
effectivement un le temps qu'on peut
perdre par rapport à des blocs qui sont
uniformes différents mais uniformes
qu'on voit de plus en plus dans le monde
et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le
morcellement qu'on pourrait avoir ce
sujet la différence et de la stratégie
européenne ne sont que des opportunités
pour eux pour être plus fort plus
puissant là où on peut paraître tout à
fait affaibli voilà ce que je voulais
souligner indiquer maintenant la
présenter
merci chers collègues
puisque la discussion est close je passe
à présent la parole à Monsieur Zidane
school pour la présentation de son
amendement
si madame la Présidente chers collègues
alors c'est un amendement très court qui
vise simplement à expliciter dans cette
délibération et donc dans le programme
de travail le fait que nous devons aussi
prendre en compte la Brigade
franco-allemande et le record et je
considère que la France et l'Allemagne
ont une responsabilité particulière
vis-à-vis de ces deux entités qui sont
des embryons en fait de défense
européenne on les doit à Helmut Cole et
François Mitterrand qui à la fin des
années 80 et au début des années 90
ont soutenu à la fois la création de
cette brigade franco-allemande dans
d'entre nous deux pays et de le record
qui réunit quelques autres pays
européens ce sont des structures qui ont
un niveau de compétence très élevé qui
réutilisent aussi très clairement une un
horizon européen auquel nous en tout cas
où on prenons nous sommes nous sommes
favorables et qu'il est important aussi
que nous continuons à travailler sur la
Brigade franco-allemande d'une part et
le record
merci chers collègues je crois qu'il y a
des
[Applaudissements]
demandes de parole sur l'amendement
une demande de parole allemande je crois
nous commençons par Monsieur Hoffman à
vous
la Brigade franco-allemande a été créé
depuis de 30 ans
et depuis à partir de la caserne de
on a fait des troupes une brigade
franco-allemande c'était très bien mais
depuis 30 ans nous sommes également
prises avec la bureaucratie
venant du ministère de la défense
allemande et français qui fait que les
troupes ne peuvent pas vraiment vivre
ensemble ni avoir des interventions
communes il y a beaucoup à faire et
c'est pourquoi je salue cette
proposition d'amendement et en tant que
démocrate libéraux nous allons être pour
chers amis nous pouvons vraiment changer
quelque chose si nous maîtrisons un
petit peu mieux nos deux
bureaucraties pour que
la coopération soit bien mieux possible
dans cette brigade franco-allemande et
c'est pourquoi je vous demande à tous de
voter pour si beaucoup
oui monsieur judo je crois avait demandé
la parole
merci Madame présidente monsieur le
Président mes chers collègue
regarde franco-allemande de records
défense européennes se sont pour le
rassemblement national des notions quasi
exotiques je vais vous citer une
citation le général de Gaulle
de 1959 il faut que la défense de la
France soit française un pays comme la
France s'il lui arrive de faire la
guerre il faut que cela soit sa guerre
et je vais lui poser la question ici ou
ou les régiments franco-allemand et le
record ont-ils combattu pour la liberté
de l'Europe on dit combattu daesh
ont-ils combattu akmi à quoi servent-ils
si vous voulez je ne pense pas qu'on ait
besoin de régiment de parade ceci n'est
pas du tout une injure faite aux
militaire excellent qui composent ces
unités mais nous n'en voyons pas
vraiment l'intérêt donc ce que je
propose c'est que l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande invite
prochainement les deux ministres de la
Défense à nous expliquer à quoi servent
ces unités je vous remercie
merci chers collègues est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres prises de parole
ça n'est pas le cas alors ce que je vous
propose en fait tous les votes vont
avoir lieu de manière solennelle cet
après-midi ce sont les présidentes qui
mettront les textes au vote donc je vous
propose maintenant que les discussions
sont closes de passer à la proposition
de résolution suivante
nielsoft tu souhaites démarrer la
présentation puisqu'il s'agit de la TV
2023,4 prend un apprentissage vivant et
efficace de la langue du partenaire
et nous sommes ensemble
à une Pringles
l'apprentissage de la langue de l'autre
est très importante parce qu'à travers
la langue on véhicule aussi bien sûr la
culture la meilleure connaissance de
l'autre et certains disent et je le
pense vraiment aussi lorsqu'on parle la
langue de l'autre et bien on s'adresse à
son cœur et les relations sont tout à
fait donc ils nous semblent importants
dans la suite aussi de ce que nos
ministres ont mis en place à savoir une
stratégie de l'apprentissage de la
langue de l'autre et bien que nous
puissions au niveau qui est le nôtre
faire un certain nombre de propositions
mais aussi veiller à ce que nos
gouvernements et pour ce qui est de
l'Allemagne on sait que ce sont les
laines d'arts qui sont qui sont
compétents mais est-ce que nos
gouvernements
entrent dans une phase concrète qui
permettent de développer cet
apprentissage de la langue de l'autre
puisque voilà vous le savez tous le
nombre d'enseignants d'Allemands en
France baisse le nombre d'enseignants de
français en Allemagne et en baisse et le
nombre d'élèves d'apprenant également
c'est tout l'objet de cette proposition
alors avant d'examiner l'amendement qui
a été déposé sur cette résolution
souhaiterais donner la parole au collège
de notre assemblée pour 2 minutes à tous
ceux qui le souhaitent alors tout
d'abord
mon collègue petit
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues je voudrais insister sur un
côté non utilitaire bien entendu nous
allons soutenir cette cette résolution
y compris je suis bien placé en tant que
député des Français qui habitent en
Allemagne je suis bien placé pour voir
la perte que nous avons vécue d'un
décennie dans l'apprentissage de
l'allemand par les Français des Français
par les Allemands mais je voudrais côté
uniquement utilitaire je crois qu'il
s'agit d'un problème fondamental
humaniste que nous traitons ici je crois
que la lingot diversité est utile à
l'humaniste autant que la biodiversité
est utile à la planète je voudrais
revenir à ce qu'est l'Union européenne
l'Union européenne c'est 24 langues
officielles on le dit jamais assez c'est
5 alphabets et quand je dis 5 alphabets
je suis gentil
c'est des longues régionales défendus
c'est une lingot diversité qui fait
partie de ce que nous considérons être
la démocratie et nous sommes attaqués
nous sommes attaqués par quelqu'un qui
dit de l'autre côté des grands-pères ont
par les Russes tu parles russes tes
enfants parleront russe parce que je
vais m'en occuper donc c'est moi le chef
mais chers collègues je crois qu'il ne
s'agit pas uniquement d'une lutte
technique qui existe nous avons des
problèmes techniques dans cette
apprentissage mais il s'agit aussi de
quelque chose de plus fondamental il ne
s'agit pas d'un combat entre l'anglais
et l'allemand en France ou entre
l'anglais et le français en Allemagne il
s'agit d'une lutte
pour la diversité des opinions et la
diversité des opinions c'est la
démocratie je vous remercie
merci monsieur Sylvain Maillard
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président oui c'est un c'est un combat
Frédéric petit vient de le dire dans des
mots que je reprendrai bien je crois que
c'était essentiel on le constate nous
apprenons de moins en moins
l'allemand pour les Français le français
pour pour les Allemands et au fond
depuis quelques années nous avons
accepté l'idée je crois qu'il faut
mettre un coup d'arrêt vous l'avez dit
madame la Présidente nous auditionnerons
dans quelques semaines les différents
ministres de l'éducation allemand et
français il faut que les plans qui ont
déjà été dévoilés se mettent en place et
que nous les accompagnons connaître les
français pour connaître l'Allemagne il
faut aussi qui est un développement fort
de l'allemand parce que c'est à travers
l'allemand le langage que nous apprenons
à nous connaître les uns les autres
c'est pas une anecdotique ce n'est pas
si ce n'est pas juste un point technique
comme l'a dit Frédéric petit c'est un
point essentiel donc oui
continuons notre surveillance aussi sur
le développement des différents plans
qui ont été annoncés et faisons en sorte
qu'à la fin de ce mandat nous ayons
progressé que les jeunes Allemands
apprennent le français que les jeunes
Français après la mort je vous remercie
à s'exprimer
merci beaucoup
en tant que groupe de gauche nous
saluons expressément cette proposition
il est très souhaitable de promouvoir
l'acquisition de la langue à l'école
mais aussi au niveau professionnel et
c'est pourquoi nous sommes heureux de ce
que au moins un endroit de la
proposition on évoque la formation
professionnelle
nous souhaitons que dans la mise en
oeuvre pratique de cette proposition
d'amendement c'est exécuté on met
l'accent car là dessus car ce n'est pas
seulement important à l'école mais aussi
pour des jeunes en formation il est
important d'organiser des programmes
de formation professionnelle
linguistique et chers collègues comme
vous l'avez dit dans la présentation de
la motion
effectivement ça ne devrait pas
s'arrêter à l'école ou au travail mais
être poursuivi pendant toute la vie donc
ça notre avis c'est un premier pas mais
il faudra encore d'autres pas pour que
les échanges entre nos pays se fassent
plus intensifs mais et c'est important
pour nous pas seulement à l'école mais
justement aussi en milieu extrascolaire
merci
merci madame la Présidente
apprendre et pratiquer une langue
étrangère c'est avant tout ouvrir son
esprit c'est aussi parvenir à mieux
comprendre la structure de pensée de
l'étranger qui sent cet effort
enthousiasmant pourrait demeurer étrange
à nos yeux il est donc essentiel que ces
ponts que ces ponts soient favorisés et
le texte que nous examinons en temps
réaffirmé la nécessité d'informer de
promouvoir de stimuler l'apprentissage
du français en Allemagne et de
l'allemand en France alors bien
évidemment mon groupe y est favorable
car la situation est en effet
inquiétante en 1994 plus de 600 000
élèves choisissaient la langue de Goeth
en France comme première langue vivante
et en 2021 il était ils étaient moins de
000 c'est les statistiques de
l'éducation nationale qui sont analysées
par l'association pour les
développements de l'allemand en France
ceux qui mettent en évidence cette
dégradation
mais cette association cette association
nous signale également que outre la
baisse du nombre d'élèves c'est le
nombre d'enseignants qui dégringolent
également puisque depuis 10 ans plus de
1000 postes d'enseignants d'Allemands en
France n'ont pas été pourvu soit plus de
70% de poste vacants en France en 2022
la conséquence directe c'est une
dégradation de la de l'enseignement de
l'allemand et des conditions de travail
des enseignants et puisqu'ils sont très
souvent obligés de travailler dans
plusieurs établissements à la fois et la
fermeture de nombreuses sections fait
qu'il n'est plus possible d'apprendre
l'allemand sur l'ensemble du territoire
français alors le rectorat ici même en
Alsace n'a pas trouvé de meilleures
solutions pour le moment que de réaliser
des jobs dating appelé sprechenzy
Deutsch ou après un entretien de 15
minutes chrono vous êtes professeur
d'allemand en capacité d'enseigner en
section bilingue donc nous dénonçons la
précarisation et la contractualisation
du métier d'enseignant il faut songer
qu'un enseignant en France gagne deux
fois moins deux fois moins qu'un ancien
néant allemand et donc là et le
véritable nerf de faux valoriser c'est
le beau et noble métier d'enseignant je
vous remercie
monsieur judo que Monsieur Hazel
merci Madame residente monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues la relance
de l'enseignement de l'Alma est une
nécessité absolue et de la langue du
pays partenaire est une nécessité
absolue si l'on veut donner du sens et
du corps
l'idée même d'amitié et de coopération
franco-allemande c'est pourquoi c'est
très résolution est à nos yeux la
bienvenue
la situation d'enseignement de
l'allemand en France et tout à fait
catastrophique le collègue a déjà
rappelé d'autres chiffres en 2001 18%
des écoliers français faisaient de
l'allemand à l'école primaire donc
aujourd'hui ils sont 3%. il y avait en
2006 10000 plus de 10000 professeurs
d'allemand ils sont aujourd'hui 5000 on
peut parler d'effondrement et je suis
pas particulièrement fier vous vous en
doutez bien de vous présenter des
chiffres aussi lamentables
il existe certes un document
ministériels franco-allemand intitulé
stratégie pour le développement de
l'apprentissage à langue du partenaire
mais quand on le regarde de près on
constate que c'est un catalogue à la
Prévert qui ne comporte aucune véritable
aucun véritable engagement opérationnel
visant à rétablir la situation c'est
pourquoi nous nous réjouissons beaucoup
de rencontrer prochainement à bonne inst
semble-t-il les deux ministres enfin en
tout cas les deux enfin le Miss français
et son homologue à peu près allemand sur
les questions éducatives pour les
interroger sur le contenu réel de leurs
intentions
car nous ne pourrons pas nous contenter
de bonnes intentions qui nous voulons
redorer le blason de l'apprentissage de
la langue des pays partenaires je vous
remercie
si monsieur
merci beaucoup Anna présidente pour là
aussi soutenir ce groupe de travail qui
a tout son sens je voudrais
effectivement insister sur le fait que
c'est le moment où nous devons vraiment
prendre conscience que le problème est
désormais très important et quand je dis
le problème est très important il y a
effectivement un effondrement de
l'enseignement de l'allemand en France
un effondrement de l'enseignement du
français en Allemagne en Allemagne quand
vous regardez il y a plus que 15% des
jeunes Allemands qui apprennent le
français qui décident de choisir le
français et effectivement les chiffres
viennent d'être cités nous avons quatre
fois moins désormais de jeunes Français
qui apprennent l'allemand donc là il
faudra aussi à travers ce groupe de
travail faire des propositions concrètes
un certain nombre d'actes simplement
indiquer que dans les dans les
propositions qui qui ont du sens c'est
que il va falloir là aussi arriver à
convaincre non seulement les élèves mais
aussi leurs parents de choisir
l'allemand et ça veut dire aussi passer
par je dirais des innovations dans la
manière de raisonner dès la classe de 6e
si on veut que l'allemand soit enseignée
en général il faut aussi proposer
l'anglais en même temps et proposer dès
la classe de 6e les deux langues il y a
un vrai travail à faire de ce côté-là et
puis ensuite je pense que nous devrons
aussi nous saisir de la partie
enseignement supérieur de cette question
là parce que encore une fois aujourd'hui
le maillon faible c'est que le nombre
d'étudiants qui poursuivent dans des
cursus germaniques en France c'est
également effondré ici à Strasbourg là
aussi alors que la faculté d'allemand
était je dirais rayonnante aujourd'hui
elle est en difficulté donc il y a
vraiment un sujet majeur et j'espère que
ce groupe de travail pourra cette
fois-ci contribuer à faire en sorte que
nous redressons la situation parce que
encore une fois c'est le moment où
jamais de tirer la sonnette d'alarme
sans quoi et bien en réalité
l'incompréhension risque d'être
croissant parce que nous le savons tous
à travers l'apprentissage de la langue
c'est aussi l'apprentissage de la
culture du voisin et ça aussi c'est
évidemment essentiel pour pouvoir et
bien intensifier notre relation
franco-allemande je vous remercie merci
chers collègues je me permets juste de
vous préciser il s'agit pas de
l'institution d'un groupe de travail non
pas qu'on ne le souhaiterait pas mais
nous en avons déjà deux qui fonctionnent
sur l'avenir de l'Europe sur la
souveraineté énergétique un troisième
qui va mettre être mis en route sur
l'harmonisation des directives ainsi
nous le validons cet après-midi sur la
politique étrangère et la sécurité ça
mobilise déjà beaucoup beaucoup de temps
et pour pour et d'énergie pour les
collègues là ce sont un certain nombre
de propositions concrètes que nous
faisons dans le cadre d'une résolution
résolution qui ensuite du mois à
l'Assemblée nationale je souhaiterais
qu'il soit reprise par notre assemblée
et que nous puissions par la suite nous
assembler parlementaire franco-allemande
bien veiller à ce que le gouvernement
met en place un certain nombre d'actions
est-ce qu'il y a encore des prises de
parole ça sur le pardon monsieur bon je
ne te vois jamais cher Vincent désolé
oui merci Madame la présente juste pour
nous se tiendrons effectivement cette
cette proposition de de résolution de
juste rassurer quand même nos collègues
allemands par rapport aux propos du
député finlandaise nous recrute nous ne
recrutons pas des profs d'allemand 15
minutes je vous rassure il y a des il y
a des concours il y a un certain nombre
de règles malgré tout donc je voudrais
quand même le faire signaler et juste
quand même un petit bémol sur la
résolution point que auquel je viens de
penser qui peut-être manque
effectivement c'est comment on arrive
aussi intégrer le monde économique nous
avons voté récemment une proposition sur
les Rasmus de l'apprentissage je pense
que c'est important aussi que le monde
économique notamment se résonne
frontalière joue leur rôle aussi de
faire connaissance à culture mais à
travers effectivement des achats des
échanges sur l'apprentissage et pas que
sur le monde
universitaire ou du second degré
puissent participer à cette partie là et
juste pour pour terminer aussi inviter
aussi peut-être qu'il manque aussi
l'aspect alors c'est vrai qu'en
Allemagne nous avons les Landers qui ont
cette compétence de l'apprentissage de
la langue en France nous avons
œuvré notamment dans la création de la
continuité européenne d'Alsace à une
décentralisation partielle en tout cas
de la promotion de cette langue d'être
invité l'état aussi à sa fille aussi sur
les collectivité en fonction de leur de
leur demande voilà ce que je voulais
rajouter de votre ongle bien entendu
cette résolution
très bien merci chers collègues nous
avons pris bonne note
je ne vois pas d'autres demandes de
prise de parole dans ce cas là je vous
propose l'examen de l'amendement et je
propose à Madame Valérie rabot de Madame
de le présenter
vous avez la parole
oui je vous remercie vivement de me
donner la possibilité
de dire un mot sur cette proposition
cela a déjà été solidia plusieurs
reprises il est important que nous
apprenions la langue de notre voisin on
en a déjà dit beaucoup de choses
j'ajouterai un point de plus cela
renforce également le respect mutuel
pour nos populations respectives et
aussi la cohésion alors justement à
notre époque c'est un potentiel énorme
qu'il faut sortir de sa latence il est
dit dans le traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle que
nous promouvons également les langues or
c'est un signe tout à fait juste et
important et en tant que parlementaire
il est étant que nous plaçons de ces
signes et de soyons forts dans la mise
en œuvre
dans la proposition d'amendement nous
avons dit clairement que nous voulons
inclure la formation professionnelle
commencez à partir des plus petits à
l'école maternelle jusqu'aux études nous
avons inclus les formations
professionnelles et les personnes
adultes car beaucoup ont appris la
langue à un moment donné de leur vie
mais essaye de rafraîchir leur
connaissance à un moment donné pour tout
cela il faut le financement adéquat et
je serai heureux si nous pouvions donner
ces impulsions je remercie en
particulier Valérie rabot qui a vraiment
donné l'impression décisive collègue
d'autres prises de parole ça n'est pas
le cas oui Frédéric petit
oui merci madame la Présidente je n'ai
pas beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure des
problèmes techniques mais je crois que
cet amendement apporte une donnée qui
est importante c'est la
constitutionnalité que ce soit en
Allemagne ou en France que je connais
mieux nous avons il faut en France il
faut que nous menions les régions je
crois aussi qu'il faudra que nous
posions la question à nos gouvernements
en France à molender de la spécificité
d'une langue par rapport aux autres je
crois que cette question va être posée
c'est à dire que quand on parle de de
double langue en sixième c'est pas non
plus pour faire de l'Espagnolet du
chinois c'est-à-dire il faudra qu'à un
moment constitutionnellement notre
assemblée travail et je crois que ça
sera le c'est ce qui est indiqué dans ce
dans cet amendement travail sur la
notion de dans le droit du pays de
reconnaissance que la langue du
partenaire est un peu plus importante
que d'autres et qu'elle doit avoir des
aménagements qui pourraient de temps en
temps faire les blocages je sais qu'en
France par exemple dès qu'on veut
promouvoir l'allemand les profs
d'espagnol
sont opposés et on a des problèmes de ce
côté-là donc je crois que cette cette
amendement est très important merci
merci beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président comme l'a dit ma collègue
Angelica nous avons tenu à la fois avec
une résolution qui arrivera après mais
que que nous retirerons pour soutenir
celles-ci ainsi amandes
nous souhaitons vraiment donner un
message très clair à nos gouvernements
alors nous avons des organisations
différentes puisque effectivement en
Allemagne ce sont les régions et nous
avons un gouvernement très centralisé
mais nous constatons que quand on est
parlementaire et qu'on va voir je parle
pour nos collègues français les recteurs
ou les inspecteurs d'académie ce sont
souvent les heures d'allemand qui font
les frais des dotations horaires donc il
est important que l'Assemblée
parlementaire franco-allemande puisse
envoyer un message à tout ce maillage
territorial
en disant il y a une résolution qui je
l'espère sera voter qu'on puisse
l'apporter aux inspecteurs d'académie au
recteurs pour qu'il y ait vraiment une
prise de conscience et un soutien du de
la dotation horaire pour ce qui concerne
l'enseignement de l'allemand peut-être
qu'il faudra mettre peut-être même aller
plus loin pour ce qui concerne la France
pour l'Allemagne c'est ça sera un schéma
différent
mais il est extrêmement important c'est
pour ça que nous avons assisté sur le la
stratégie de relance en tenant compte
des spécificités et puis nous avons
aussi souhaité insister sur le rôle des
enseignants les enseignants en
participent par exemple en France à la
Quinzaine franco-allemande que nous
organisons dans la région Occitanie
ces démarches là doivent aussi être
valorisées et valoriser par les
inspections et les rectorats qui parfois
peine à en tenir compte donc ce point là
nous paraît être extrêmement important
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Fernandez
Thiébault et pour tout le monde j'ai ici
l'offre l'offre d'emploi je prêche Andy
Deutsch donc les job dating par
l'Académie Strasbourg pour devenir
effectivement professeur enseignant
d'allemand en section primaire donc je
mets à disposition de documents à mon
collègue monsieur Thiébault donc pour le
job dating je précise 15 minutes et vous
êtes enseignant d'allemand en primaire
merci
je ne vois pas d'autres demandes de
prise de parole dans ce cas là donc le
texte comme les autres sera soumis cet
après-midi avec votre amendement madame
Glockner et Madame rabot au vote
solennelle de notre assemblée
et du coup je vous laisse présenter
madame rabot madame Glockner
la résolution la proposition de
résolution commune ou
voilà ça change que vous avez le soutien
des deux co-présidents du bureau sur
l'amendement que vous venez de présenter
madame rabot madame blocner
nous allons retirer cette proposition
merci chers collègues
nous arrivons de ce fait à la
proposition de résolution commune
20-23-1 promotion de la mittente par des
mesures d'accompagnement dans les
domaines de l'audiovisuel et de
l'industrie si cinématographique commune
présentée par Monsieur judo et Monsieur
kleinwechter monsieur studio
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues
le sens de ce projet de résolution
commune et de raffermir les liens entre
les peuples de développer la
connaissance et la compréhension
mutuelle et de créer une plus grande
proximité culturelle entre nous deux
peuples
nous pensons en effet que l'amitié
franco-allemande dans ses manifestations
est un modèle qui s'essouffle
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire dans
les mystique de l'Assemblée nationale il
y a les signaux forts que nous avons
constaté tout à l'heure s'agissant de la
dégradation de l'enseignement de la
langue du partenaire d'une part
il y a aussi un certain nombre de de
signes qui montrent que nous les
éloignons les uns des autres en matière
de connaissance mutuelle dans les médias
si on accepte Arte la part de
productions allemandes
et minime
téléspectateurs français voit très peu
de films allemands très peu de musique
de il entend très peu de musique de
variétés allemandes il entend il voit
très peu de séries dans les journaux
d'information télévisées on parle très
très peu de l'Allemagne très rarement
hors des catastrophes bien sûr donc
notre projet de résolution tente à
remonter la pente du déclin de la
routine et du ronron institutionnel dans
lequel selon nous au rassemblement
national
est en train de se perdre la relation
franco-allemande nous souhaitons donc
que l'Assemblée parlementaire
franco-allemande demande au gouvernement
de promouvoir dans les grands médias la
connaissance de la culture
du mode de vie et de la société du pays
partenaire c'est le sens des paragraphes
8 et 9 de la du projet de résolution
nous demandons également qu'un prix
franco-allemand du film par graphe 10
puissent être institué qui aurait selon
nous une valeur de symboles de la
volonté commune devrait dans le champ
culturel partagé je vous remercie
beaucoup j'appelle monsieur birkwald
présent chers collègues
ce cette proposition évidemment c'est ce
point
charmant moi aussi je
ce qu'il en est du point de vue de ce
que le collègue judo vient de dire au
point de vue de connaissance du mode de
vie ces informations les séries oui mais
c'est vrai que si nous voyons davantage
de séries françaises c'est parce
qu'elles sont si bonnes et je me réjouis
de ce que tout à l'heure nous allons
avoir la possibilité de rendre visite à
Arte pour nous faire notre opinion
propre Arte forme de coopération est une
chaîne qui n'existe nulle part ailleurs
contre la France et l'Allemagne je suis
très heureux de ce que nous ayons Arte
mon groupe va refuser cette proposition
et pour différentes raisons j'en citerai
au point 4 il est question du projet de
action dont il dit qu'il doit être
libéré de toute idiotie madame c'est
Monsieur c'est impossible de se libérer
complètement de toute idéologie il y a
des libéraux il y a des socialistes il y
a des conservateurs
jamais n'arriverez-vous à un texte ni à
une déclaration politique exemple de
toute trace d'idéologie celui qui écrit
ça n'a aucune idée de ce qu'il écrit
donc déjà pour ça nous ne pouvons pas
signer mais il y a un point plus
important c'est le dernier le point
d'eau supprimer la redevance
audiovisuelle en Allemagne comme la
France l'a déjà fait bien la France peut
le faire c'est le souhaite et elle fera
ses propres expériences en la matière
cela ne regarde pas en Allemagne mais la
redevance audiovisuelle en Allemagne
nous ne voudrions pas du tout la
supprimer en effet nous avons de très
bonnes raisons de NE vient de faire
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale en
effet nous avons pris la décision que
nous ne voulions pas de radio Diffusion
d'État mais une radio diffusion publique
financée par des redevances bien sûr on
peut discuter du montant des redevances
je ne vous le cacherai pas je ne serais
certainement pas le seul allemand ici
dans la salle qui s'énerve de temps en
temps à cause des redevances mais ce
n'est pas une raison leur montant n'est
pas une raison pour les supprimer on
peut en discuter donc nous refuserons
cette notion
merci madame la Présidente alors je
pense que tout a mis des arts et de la
culture audiovisuel votera évidemment
contre ce texte puisque le coeur de
l'affaire est tout de même une espèce
peut étrange entre le programme qui est
cité ici d'Emmanuel Macron ne
suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle qui lui était justifié par
une hostilité à toute audiovisuel public
fort et l'hostilité est assez classique
finalement de l'extrême droite
européenne vis-à-vis de la liberté de la
presse d'autant que la première victime
d'une telle adoption serait Arte donc
vous êtes en train de nous vendre une
coopération franco-allemande en retirant
les moyens à ceux qui coopèrent c'est
une idée effectivement formidable en
outre à la lecture il saute aux yeux que
il manquait peut-être quelques heures de
travail pour savoir ce qui existe en
termes de coopération franco-allemande
vous dites on veut concurrencer les
productions États-Unis et chinoises ça
tombe bien il y a Arte vous voulez le
liquider en retirant la redevance alors
si jamais vous cherchez à Arte c'est la
touche 5 sur la télécommande en France
donc n'hésitez pas deuxièmement vous
dites que vous voulez mettre en place un
fond de soutien et un prix du film
c'est une idée qui est excellente elle
est d'ailleurs tellement qu'on a créé
l'Académie franco-allemande du cinéma en
l'an 2000 sous tutelle du CNC et du bof
tracteur fukulto ou une médiane vous
prenez également des prix et une
production de distribution
franco-allemande renforcée ce qui est
excellent
opportun d'autant plus que depuis 2003
il y a les rendez-vous franco-allemand
du cinéma qui s'occupe de ça donc vous
arrivez peut-être 20 ans après avec une
idée qui est déjà en place finalement on
attend avec impatience une prochaine
résolution qui vise à réinventer l'eau
chaude on a bien compris ici que tout
cela était un prétexte à la suppression
des dotations publiques récurrentes et
pérenne pour l'audiovisuel et la
production culturelle donc tout ce qui
est censure par les suppressions de
dotation ce sera non
merci chers collègues madame buffet
Françoise buffet n'a pas de bander la
parole pardon madame rigole
merci merci madame la Présidente bonjour
mes chers collègues mon collègue Adrien
cloué a déjà beaucoup dit de ce que
cette proposition resons de manque de
culture et d'absence de culture je
rajouterai juste deux éléments sur la
culture franco-allemande vous parlez des
séries je vous conseille de regarder
dark qui est une série qui est eu un
succès mondial qui est passionnante qui
montre que la SF se fait aussi très bien
en Europe j'en cite qu'une seule ou
alors je vous invite à venir au très bon
festival pour faire local à Hogan Blick
qui est un festival de film
franco-allemand mais peut-être peut-être
est-il trop métissé trop coloré au goût
de mes collègues et peut-être que c'est
oublier que nos pays et l'Europe sont
aussi le fruit de cette diversité pour
être plus sérieuse et concentrée sur le
sujet qui nous occupe la suppression de
la redevance effectivement a été votée
en France ce qui rend Arte première
victime de ça et donc la audiovisuel qui
lit nos deux pays
certes l'État français pour l'instant
compense ce qui permet aux Allemands de
ne pas avoir à retirer leur dotation
mais jusqu'à quand et sur quelle
stabilité pouvons-nous continuer à
penser que nous garderons cet outil de
promotion de nos cultures du métissage
de nos cultures et de nos langues
communes à travers la culture nous ne
savons pas par dessus ça nos chers
collègues de l'extrême droite souhaitent
donc rajouter la suppression des
dotations pérennes côté allemand pour
mettre à mort totalement nos cultures
communes notre création contemporaine et
l'avenir que nous pouvons créer ensemble
je pense que la messe est dit tout le
monde aura compris que côté écologiste
le vote sera contre
merci chers collègues monsieur Delaporte
merci madame la Présidente
ce qui est de bien avec les
nationalistes l'extrême droite et les
mouvements populistes en Europe mais
aussi en France et en Allemagne puisque
le RN c'est associé à la FD pour déposer
cette résolution c'est qu'il ne nous
déçoivent jamais
mon collègue cloué disait que cette
résolution réinventer l'eau chaude mais
moi je dirais plutôt qu'elle me fait
froid dans le dos vous parlez de
libéraliser et désidéologiser
l'information mais ce qu'on constate
dans les régimes autoritaires où vos
amis ont pris le pouvoir en Europe comme
ailleurs c'est que l'information n'est
pas libérée elle est cadenassée
ce qu'on constate en Europe et ailleurs
c'est que vous voulez supprimer les
moyens pour le service public de la
culture que vous dites ici défendre mais
finalement la suppression de la
redevance ce n'est que l'affaiblissement
d'une information plus réaliste et vous
êtes opposé au pluralisme c'est pour ça
que nous sommes évidemment opposés
fermement à cette idéologie à cette
résolution tout en sachant que quand on
est contre les idéologies il reste
toujours derrière une idéologie et
celle-ci elle est profondément
nauséabonde je finirai enfin par une
boutade au camarades cloué Arte c'est la
touche 7 et non la touche 5 en France
merci chers collègues je ne vois plus de
demandes de prise de parole c'est pardon
collègue Emmanuel Lacresse désolé je ne
vous avais pas vu sur collègue merci
madame la Présidente où il faut
effectivement s'opposer à ce projet de
résolution parce qu'il n'est pas du tout
question de favoriser le dialogue entre
les deux peuples il s'agit effectivement
d'une entreprise idéologique je passe
sur le fait qu'il est question de
proposer un fond franco-allemand puisque
déjà au Festival de Cannes depuis le 17
mai 2001 un accord entre la France et
l'Allemagne avait été passée et qui
produit toujours ses fruits il suffit de
consulter la liste des films
franco-allemands qui ont été financés
par exemple l'an dernier la rédaction de
la résolution est donc excessivement
critique sur le bilan actuel et surtout
les acteurs la résolution par le
déshydroliser et de même de contrôler
l'information des peuples donc c'est un
une attaque virus Roger collection
européenne alors que ce projet
collection européenne qui associe
[Musique]
merci beaucoup chers collègues donc
avant que je ne dise que le débat est
clos je pique il y a pas d'autres
demandes de prise de parole
ça ne semble pas être le cas
là notre réunion pour ce matin est
terminée nous allons suspendre nos
débats je vous propose comme il y a des
trains des avions à prendre et que nous
arrivons la terminer un petit peu plus
tôt que prévu de démarrer à 14h15
précise la séance en présence de nos
deux présidentes donc cet après-midi je
le rappelle il y aura le vôtre
solennelle de l'ensemble des textes
l'audition des ministres et le débat sur
les Balkans
occidentaux donc on se retrouve tous à
14h15 ici dans l'hémicycle nous allons
maintenant nous diriger vers l'endroit
du déjeuner qui se trouve on va on va
vous guider dans la salle de restaurant
tous tout simplement
à tout à l'heure chers collègues et mes
merci pour les échanges riches de ce
matin